تنتقموا منا في الاولاد انتقموا منا في
الاولاد
معلش ارجع انا لله يا اشرف وانا اليه
راجعون ارجعوا يا
شباب انا
لله وانا اليه راجعون رب العالمين اللي
نتحمله
وبس يخسع جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ص
قلب يلا ماشي المدنيه
هذه دموع الانسانيه اللي شفتوها يلا ثواني
بس مش دموع الانهيار والخوف والجبل ول يخس
جيش الاحتلال ول يخس جيش
[موسيقى]
الاحتلال مكين الوهن اضناني وعن اخواني
قيدني وعن قدس وما كنفت وغز هاشم الجمني
فلا دين يحركه ولا قوم يغلبه كراسي الذل
تخطفه يناجيها كاوثون مكين الوهن اضناني
فصار سجني يا وطني اعيش به كعام يجوي ليضع
فني فلا اقصى يناديه ولا مجد سيغر فجمع
المال يلهيه عن السكرات والكفن ولو دامت
لسالفه لما وصلت لكفه كذا الايام تطويه
يوار دون سلطان مكين الوهن اضناني وعن
اخواني قيدني فلا نصر بلا جمع ولا عز مع
الهود تكتب فتاه
فلسطينيه الى
العناوين قمه السلام في زمن الحرب تختتم
دون بيان
ختامي هل ابو الغيط بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين بنفير وحاخامات يشكلون فرق
موت من
المستوطنين
حاخام يفتي بقتل اطفال فلسطين دون
رحمه كاهن فلسطيني مسيحي سيرفع الاذان عن
المسلمين اذا لزم
الامر ضابط امريكي حماس ست تل جنود
اسرائيل اذا دخلوا
غزه مسنه اسرائيليه مفرج عنها تحرج تل
ابيب بحديثها عن حسن اخلاق
حماس التهدئه بالقران مع نفاد البنج في
العمليات
الجراحيه ملياردير امريكي لا يستبعد ان
تشكل غزه شراره حرب
عالميه
مرحبا لكل من يسال لماذا احتضنت القاهره
قمه السلام التي عجزت عن توليد بيان ختامي
ولم تدعو جامعه الدول العربيه ومنظمه
التعاون الاسلامي الى قمه قرار تنقذ
الفلسطينيين في غزه والضفه من تداعي الامم
عليهم نقول له ما خصك خليك بشغلك خبزك
بهمك ولا تعلم الامناء العامين على ما يجب
وما لا يجب فهم اعلم من الجميع بالواجب
وان لم يفعلوه مقومات الحياه في اسرائيل
ليست من داخلها وانما من خارجها
ويوجد عنصران اساسيان هما الدعم الامريكي
بلا حدود ام والثاني الغياب العربي ايضا
بلا حدود انتهت قمه الق ره للسلام حول غزه
دون بيان ختامي وقد اصدرت مصر بيانا
منفردا يعبر عن خيبه الامل من انعدام
التوافق لوقف العدوان على غزه وارجعت
مصادر دبلوماسيه هذا التعثر الى رفض الدول
العربيه ضغوطا اوروبيه سعت لتضمين البيان
ادانه صريحه لحركه حماس والمقاومه
واعترافا بحق اسرائيل فيما وصف بالدفاع عن
نفسها يعني ذلك ان الاوروبيين والغرب
يريدون من العرب تمجيد القاتل وتسفيه
المقتول الذي صدف وجوده تحت صواريخ
اسرائيل اللطيفه التي تنشر السلام والمحبه
بختم دولي مصدق من قوى النوويه تغزو من
تريد وتعفو عم من تشاء من شعوب يتي
على موائد دكتاتوريات لئيمه تميزت كلمه
الامين العام للجامعه العربيه احمد ابو
الغيط بالتوازن حيث امسك العصى من وسطها
وساوى بين المدنيين
الفلسطينيين وتجميعه المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين
المحتلين علما ان مركز الازهر للفتوى لا
يرى ان مستوطني الارض المحتله ينطبق عليهم
وصف
المدنيين بل هم محتلون للارض مغتصبون للحق
معتدون على المقدسات وذلك في فتوى نشرها
الموقع الالكتروني الرسمي لمركز الازهر
العالمي للفتوى قبل ان يتم حذفها في وقت
لاحق اؤكد على ان الجامعه العربيه ترفض
كافه انواع الاستهداف والعنف ضد
المدنيين دون تمييز بهيز عدو السلام
والتطبيع
الرومانتيكي ليس معنا اليوم فهو معاقب
لانه اقترح على فريق الاعداد هذا المقطع
الغنائي المسرحي الحزين بدلا عن البيانات
الختاميه للقمم العربيه القادمه
انعقدت
ح
بحر
السفي
اخ اخ يا دمع بلغها
سلامي
اخ
اخبي نبوع
الشام غرقنا ب بحر الندامي موجت الدمعه
الدافي
دار حزن
ان
طها
بحري
فان
السب في غياب قدرتك على فعل شيء لمناصري
المظلومين يبقى لك لسانك ودعائك وقلبك
وقلمك لكنك اذا كتبت كلمه حق اعلم انك
ستجد من يسارع الى اتهامك بالاستعراض فاذا
دخلت الى حساب بعضهم هؤلاء
المعترضين ستجدهم يتبنون روايه المحتل
القاتل ويستعرضون تبريراته بكل خنوع في
المقابل مندوب ليبيا في البرلمان العربي
حسن البرغوثي قال كلمه حق وطالب بفتح
الحدود مع غزه لاختبار قوه الليبيين اقسم
بالله العظيم لا عندي دره شك في كل
موجودين في القاعه ان قلوبهم وقفت وتاثرت
ولكن ما نحن فاعلون اذا كان في خطوات
فاعله حقيقيه تبقوا توافقوا عليها كبرلمان
عربي فهذا الوقت مناسب اقسم بالله العظيم
لو في اليه لفتح الحدود اقسم بالله وانا
مسع كلامي وكلكم تعرفوا الضع اللي في
ليبيا علي نعم السلاح اللي في ليبيا كلهم
يقولو لي غزه وقاعدين مقاتلين عندنا كلهم
موجودين ومتدربين لو في اليه لفتح الحدود
وانا مسؤول عن كلامي لطالما انتقدنا ووصف
فنه وما زلنا نصفه بالها
لكن الموقف الشهم الرجولي لا نستطيع ان
نتجاوزه بين محمد رمضان واحمد ابو الغيط
اجمع فريق الاعداد اعداد هذه الحلقه على
اختيار رمضان بالتزكيه لامانه جامعه الدول
العربيه على الاقل بيعرف يعمل حاجه
وعايزين صوتنا يوصل يوصل لمين اح عايزين
صوتنا يوصل لمين بره بره
بلادنا صوتنا يوصل لبلاد
بلادنا بلادنا عندها جيوش وعندها اسلحه
وبنشتري اسلحه وبنشتري دبابات وبنشتري
طيارات وبنسيب لحد ما تصدي وتترمي ونشتري
غيرها هنستخدمها امتى اسلحتنا وجيشنا
وجيوشه وصوتنا يوصل لمين بره احنا عايزين
مين بره يدافع
عننا ده قمه الجبن وقمه عدم الرجوله وقمه
لما لما نقول احنا عايزين نكتب الانجلش
عشان بره يعرفوا ان احنا بنضرب وانت وانت
فين انت فين بلدك وفين
جيشك صوتك يوصل ل
حكومتك قول ل حكومتك طلع السلاح وروح حارب
في الوقت الذي تعجز فيه الارجنتين وجزر
السيشل وسكان غابات الامازون عن توصيل
شربه ماء الى غزه وزع وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي المتطرف ايتمار بن فير صورا
لتسليح مستوطنين اسرائيليين يقال عنهم
مدنيون في اسرائيل واعلن عن انشاء نحو 500
وحده قتاليه
احتياطيه منذ بدايه الحرب على غزه كذلك
قام حاخام مستوطنه قرب بيت اللحم بما
يعتبره واجبه الكهنوتي فوزع الاسلحه
الناريه على بعض مستوطنيه مدني
موصيا اياهم باطلاق النار على كل من يقترب
من سياج المستوطنه حتى يكونوا مواطنين
صالحين حاخام يهودي صادق لم يستعمل التقيه
ولا المجامله قالها بكل ثقه وايمان ان
التوراه وضعت قوانين الحرب التي تسمح بمحو
الجميع النساء والاطفال والرجال فهؤلاء لا
حق لهم في الوجود ولا رحمه بالطفل لانه
سيكبر ويقتل على حد تعبير حضره
الحاخام الذي تبكي داعش في الزاويه متاثره
بخطابه
العاطفي being merciful to the child
being vious to the ultimate victim that
this child will grow up and
kill because the
ideology that child will grow up
with is even worse ideology of his
father the reason why the in the book of
deuteronomy chapter 20
says rules of war
نما do not all any to alive
nothing no
mercy
furore deuteronomy
19 complet
er any
m
جيش الاحتلال وبما قد يعتبر التزاما منه
بفتوى حضره الحاخام المخلص لعقيدته حول
وجوب قتل الاطفال لم يقصر ابدا والارقام
الاوليه تتكلم وفي حصيله غير نهائيه تجاوز
عدد الاطفال القتلى جراء العدوان
الاسرائيلي على القطاع اكثر من
1700 منذ السابع من اكتوبر ونحو 30 طفلا
في الضفه الغربيه في المده نفسها ولا يزال
هناك مئات الاطفال في عداد المفقودين تحت
انقاض المباني المدمره في القطع الامين
العام لجامعه الدول العربيه احمد ابو
الغيط لم يحسم حتى الان وجود حرب دينيه
يشنها جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على
الفلسطينيين بل قال ان لدينا خشيه كبرى من
الانجراف الى صراع ديني في المنطقه كما ان
لدينا خشيه كبرى من الانجراف الى صراع
ديني يلحق كارثه ممتده بالبشريه رئيس
جمعيه كورسيكا اسرائيل ديفيد انتونيلي
يخبر المذيع انه يهودي متدين ويردده سكان
غه onit rup en fin d'histoire certes
mais voil on y est peut mo je me fich
perd des gaz moi ce qui m' aujourd'hui
c'est la vengeance des 1300 isra mais
honn je n'ai rien faire de ce devenir
2000 personnes gaza ثالث اقدم كنيسه في
العالم واقدم كنيسه مفتوحه في غزه تعرضت
لقصف اسرائيلي هي كنيسه القديس بوري
فوريوس التابعه للكنيسه الارثوذكسيه
اليونانيه القصف الاسرائيلي هدم جزء منها
في وقت كان يختبئ فيها نحو 500 مدني مع من
الاطفال والنساء ما ادى الى سقوط عدد من
الضحايا اقرت اسرائيل قبل عده سنوات قانون
يهوديه الدوله الذي يحول اسرائيل الى دوله
دينيه يحظى فيها اليهود على امتيازات
الدرجه الاولى في مقابل مشروع الدوله
الفلسطينيه الذي لم يطرح اصحابه على مختلف
توجهاتهم مشروع قانون اسلاميه الدوله
ولنستمع جميعا ليستمع تحديدا المطبع العرب
الى الكاهن الفلسطيني المسيحي الارثوذكسي
انطونيوس حنانيا ماذا قال مؤخرا في مؤتمر
نداء الاقصى الدولي لا يريدون استقلالا
لنا انه البعض يحاول دائما ان يظهر
الموضوع وكانه مسيحيين فلسطين محيدين انما
يتعرضون لابشع انواع الاضطهاد تعرضوا
للصحفيه شيرين ابو عاقله وحاولوا اسقاط
تابوتها ولكن المسلمين في فلسطين رفعوا
التابوت ودافعوا عن تابوت شيرين ابو عاقلي
ولو كان هذا شيخا دافعت عنه كما دافعوا عن
شيرين وانا اقول لك كما قال كما قالها
الاب منويل مسلم مرارا وتكرارا خليهم
يمنعوا الاخوه الاسلام في فلسطين ان
يرفعوا الاذان ومحسوبه اللي قاعد هون انا
برفع
[موسيقى]
الاذان وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي وعد جنوده
بانهم سيرون غزه قريبا من الداخل فاعتبر
وعيدا لهم وليس وعدا علق متابعون فاخر ما
يتمناه جنود نتنياهو هو دخول غزه يا رجل
غزه عندهم للطائرات وليست للمشد لقطات من
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه سمح ان تصور
تظهر وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي وف جالنت وهو
يتناقش مع القاده العسكريين ربما عن الخطه
الاخيره للهجوم البري الوشيك على غزه اما
في مركز القياده هذا القريب من غلاف غزه
فيحفز يواف جالانت الجنود الاسرائيليين
على النصر قائلا انهم قريبا سيرون غزه من
الداخل هذا جندي اسرائيلي لم يعد عنده
زملاء يكملون طاوله الشده ورق اللعب كلهم
قتلوا على ذمته عندما كان يشتم رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو اثناء زيارته
قاعده عسكريه في منطقه غلاف غزه
نتنياهو انت خربت الدوله قال
له سكوت ريتر ضابط مخابرات امريكي سابق
يحب اسرائيل بصدق واخلاص ويريد السلامه
لجنودها فينصح حكومه تلبيب كما يفعل الابو
العطوف ويقول لها جنودكم غير جاهزين
للمعركه انهم خائفون حتى الموت انهم
ذاهبون الى كمين كبير والاستخبارات
الاسرائيليه عمياء حماس تنتظرهم
وستقتصر so now they're back but this
time they're being called upon to do
something that nobody in israel wants to
do go gaza why 2014 they went into gaza
and hamas handed it to the israeli army
just isn't that good and they're scared
to death because hamas is waiting for
them this is one giant ambush and the
israeli intelligence is blind they don't
know where they are they're going to
have to go in there
and bl up
ed نظر عن تقييم الضابط الامريكي
للمعنويات المهترئه للجندي الاسرائيلي لكن
هل سيصمد الغزيون امام قصف جحيمي يستهدف
الاطفال والنساء قبل غيرهم ويمحو عائلات
عن الوجود على خارطه غزه والله لو كل
دورنا راحه لو كل اهالينا راحوا لو كل
مالنا راح
ماساو والله لو شلنا والله لو ما لقنا حد
يس فلنا ماساو والد فلسطيني فقد ابنه
البكر بقصف اسرائيلي عشوائي فسجد سجده شكر
في المستشفى على ما اعتبره خاتمه مرضيه
داعيا ذوي الشهداء الى الصبر والصمود ما
تعيط يا زلمه انت زلمه كلنا شهداء كلنا
مشاريع شهداء كم من شهيد الك انت والله
ابني الكبير ابن
الكبير قبل هدلك حد ولد الله يرحمه قل انا
لله وان اليه راجعون اللهم اجرني في مصبت
واخلفني من خير منها سامحوا ابن عمك
سامحوا مالكم يا عمي شدوا حيلكم ارض جهاد
هذه وارض رباط كنا في سبيل الله احنا ليش
عايشين بكره بياخذك من ايده وبخش شك
الفردوس الاعلى الشهيد بتشبع ل 70 واحد من
اهل بيته وهذا ابو اخر استشهدت كل اسرته
تقريبا بقصف منزلها لكنكم لن تصدقوا كيف
واجه الماسات حلو يا عم روح الشهدا احنا
بنوزع حلو عشان اودي كلهم استشهدوا وزوجتي
يا عم ماضلي الا ولد كان واقف على باب
المخبز يجيب
خبز فاهم كيف وانا رحت اجيب اعبي قل ميه
احنا ادنا وبناتنا بموتوا اولادنا واحنا
بدنا نموت هان احنا بدنا نموت هانش تهجير
بدك تضرب الشفا اضرب بدك تضرب تضرب بدنا
نستشهد ه من قلب مشهد الموت والدمار يجد
لينون مكانا للابتسامه فالقتل الاسرائيلي
لم يعد يخيفهم انا اسمي صالح وان شاء الله
انت صالح يا
رب هذا تقويم انت حلو من
غير عليك يا
صالح والله يا حاجه موليد 44 انتش يعني
مليد قبل النكبه انت اقدم من اسرائيل طبعا
اه اه انا موجوده يعني هذا الشي بثبت انه
احنا ايش فلسطين ارضنا طبعا غصب عنهم انا
متمسكه في الارض يا طبعا اقول بلدي لو
تتحد عل ماريا واهلي لو قسيوا علي حنان في
غزه الان عمليات جراحيه تجرى للصغار
والكبار بدون تخدير مع نفاده في بعض
المستشفيات قراءه القران الكريم عوضا عن
البنج هكذا غالب طفل جريح الامه اثناء
اجراء عمليه جراحيه له في ساقه بعد ان كان
احد اهداف بنك العدوان الاسرائيلي اعوذ
بالله من
الشيطان
الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم وقضى ربك الا
تعبدوا الا
اياه الا اياه و
لوالدين احسانا المعدات الطبيه محدوده جدا
و نشتغل باقل الامكانيات
امي ثم امي لحد اخري و في
عمري ثم ياتيك المتصهين مجدي خليل كما
يوصف ليدعي ان ما في غزه هو اضعاف اضعاف
ما هو موجود في مصر وقديما قيل اذا كذبت
فبالغ حتى تصبح كذابا فالفرق ليس شاسعا
بين الكاذب والكذاب غزه محاصره من ناحيه
السلاح من ناحيه السلاح اما الغذاء فغزا
فيها اكل اضعاف اضعاف اللي موجود في مصر
غزه لم تكن تعاني بالذات في اخر خم وست
سنين بيشتغلوا داخل اسرائيل عندهم فائض في
كل شيء ما عندهمش اي مشكله صحيح ان جنود
الاحتلال خائفون من غزه كما يقرون لكن هل
ان الاسرائيليين الوحيدين غير الخائفين
الان هم من اسرتهم حماس مسنه اسرائيليه
مفرج عنها من غزه تحرج نتنياهو وجيشه
وحكومته بعد اشادت باخلاق المقاومه
[موسيقى]
الفلسطينيه given the medic they given
medic and they were treated one of the
men with them had badly injured from
from a motorbike accident on the way and
the paramedic was looking after his
wounds it was
given medicine and
antibiotics the people friendly that
they kep the place very clean my
speaking
[موسيقى]
الملياردير الامريكي الشهير راي داليو لا
يبدو انه مقتنع بان تحركا عسكريا امريكيا
ضخما جديدا باتجاه الشرق الاوسط سببه
الحرب على قطاع غزه الصغير المساحه
المحاصر من الجهات الست فهو يعتبر ان
احداث غزه قد رفعت احتمالات نشوب حرب
عالميه الى نسبه
50% بهدف اعاده تشكيل العالم السياسي نوشك
على حرب كبرى سيولد معها نظام عالمي جديد
كلمات على لسان ري داليو الملياردير
الامريكي الشهير داليو الذي صنفته بلومبير
كواحد من اكثر 50 شخصا نفوذا في العالم
رفع توقعاته باحتمال نشوب حرب عالميه
ثالثه الى 50% بدلا من
35% قبل عامين والسبب الحرب في غزه معبرا
عن زياده مخاوفه من احتماليه تورط
الولايات المتحده والصين في مواجهه مباشره
رحمه زين زينه النساء المصريات تواجه
اعلام الغرب بما يفهمه جمهوره وامثال زينه
ساهموا في تعديل مؤشرات الراي العام
العالمي لصالح
الفلسطينيين
المعارض السوري فراس الاسد ابن عم الرئيس
لم يرق له تباكي موالي للنظام السوري على
غزه والفلسطينيين زعلانين خايفين على اهل
غزه انه بده يهجرهم تطهير عرقي انتم
حضراتكم زعلانين وخايفين على الفلسطينيين
انه يتهجن من ارضهم بشار الاسد هجر س
ملايين سوري سب ملايين سوري وين كنتم
ملايين السوريين عايشين بالخيام مئات
الالاف قتلوا يعني انتم
بلوعه البلد يعني انتم رضيتوا انه الروسي
يدمر مدن سوريا فوق رؤوس اطفال ونساء
سوريه جاي هلا تزعلي
[موسيقى]
الفلسطيني ختاما سال صحفي طفلا في غزه
ماذا تحب ان تصبح حين تكبر فاجابه وهل
نكبر يا عمي في غزه نحن نموت صغارا لانه
يعيش بقربنا اشخاص لا يحبون لنا ان نعيش
فيقتلون على اسرتنا او على مقاعد مدرستنا
او حين نلعب كره القدم او عند نسبح مع
اهلنا على شاطئ
مدينتنا يضيف الطفل النبيه محظوظ يا عمي
منا من يعيش اكثر ليصبح شابا يستشهد
برصاصه في صدره وليس في ظهره وليس تحت
انقاض منزل قرر طيار
تدميره اما من يربح الحظ منا فهو من يتزوج
وينجب اطفالا يحرسون الدار قبل اي يموت
الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء ايش بتلعب ايش
بتلعبوا شو
بتلعب لازم
[موسيقى]
تلعب ايش
بتحكها
[موسيقى]
ا